in this video i'm gonna give you my 20  best gift ideas for women a purse  organizer i personally think  every woman needs a first organizer  because have you looked at a woman's  purse i mean  it's there's always a lot of stuff in  there and they just keep on pulling  stuff out  nice plant  it's always good to have something green  in the house and most women they love  plants  get her something for her hobby you just  need to know what she likes to do most  women will start to talk about their  hobbies anyway when you just show a  little bit of interest so keep your ears  up all right guys the bonus tip  and this is the best tip that you can  get any woman out there in the world  and it is  your love  you need to make her feel loved and very  important appreciate it  if you already do that then any other  gift that you will get her will just  mean so much more to her